you have two new projects out um one is
minx i'm obsessed it's a cheeky comedy
that presents women in a
multi-dimensional way there's a
character she wants to start like a
feminist magazine but she meets jake
johnson who's so cute and adorable
and he runs like lady magazines they
it matriculates into them making a
magazine for women
with
male naked men exactly
why is the male body trending right now
paul like you watch hbo euphoria minx
like these projects like what is it
about women and men who are all of a
sudden like you know what would be the
greatest trend ever mail
i think it's because it hasn't been done
a lot in the past there haven't been a
lot of like full frontal men on
in movies and tv no there really hasn't
been it's not like a trend it's like a
revelation
who knew that what guys were packing
right
well we all knew it just apparently we
didn't want to see it now we realized we
got a bite of the apples
and we want more
so
congratulations
and thank you for bringing that to the
forefront now welcome to flat
is a beautiful show that feels in
keeping with you when i think of two
tones that are my personal
north stars and most important which is
heart and humor what spoke to you about
this project and what should we be
thinking as we watch it going into it
well
like you say heart and humor that's what
i love about it it's based on a bbc show
called this country and this is the art
we made an american version of it and
it's about a small town i grew up in a
small town in michigan so we really love
small towns and the people in them and
this was a way to kind of show that off
and have fun with those people not
making fun of them by by any means
having fun with all the people you know
when you're in a small town it's like
being in high school you're kind of
trapped in this place with these people
but then you get you have a love for
those people and so it's a really sweet
show but it's very very funny yes 100
now i have to ask you as a last question
when you met with melissa mccarthy for
bridesmaids what did you see
a brilliant person actually well she
comes in and she started to do the
audition and she did it so different
from the way anybody else did it it took
me a good 10 to 15 seconds to go to
realize it was funny because i was
literally going like what is she doing
and then you go like i think this is the
funniest thing i've ever seen
well it led to an academy award
nomination there you go which in comedy
is the hardest thing to do yeah
welcome to flash airs thursday nights on
fox with the first seven episodes
streaming now on hulu also check out the
hit series minx we're all gonna enjoy it
it's got new episodes available
thursdays on hbo max who seems to know
what everybody wants right now
paul feige i'm your biggest fan thank
you for coming on the show
[Music]
you